hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to show you two other squeeze
opportunities that i have identified
by using the market cap the volume the
synthetic short interest the regular
short interest and of course technical
analysis i'm going to show you here all
of this and see what we can do let's get
into it
[Music]
all right so
my two candidates are marine and groupen
all right grpn and mrin are the tickers
so let's start with uh marina
so what do we have here we can see that
the stock was basically rengi
for
a few years
and suddenly
in june we had a massive massive move up
from 1
to 27 all right so this is a squeeze
guys all right so here there was a
squeeze i wasn't there i mean i was
there but i was not using my spreadsheet
at that time so i didn't see this one
but this is a beautiful squeeze
and after that we had a pump and a dump
okay
so then i had here many of you asking me
questions uh in my discord link in the
description by the way if you are
interested that were telling me should i
get in should i not get in and i was
here seeing a clear downtrend
that found support here's this is a fake
out then we had this right so basically
this was not easy to trade we had a lot
of weakness i didn't give any alerts on
this here we didn't have the breakout
and right now i'm seeing something
interesting guys because let's go on the
first time frame okay so on the first
time frame we can see that here we had
this consolidation with the market
making lower lows with the macd going
higher all right this is a bullish
divergence we have it under four hours
do we have it on a daily
we don't have it on the daily do we have
it on the hourly and we have it on the
hourly so we have two time frames with
this bullish divergence you can see here
the magazine is going higher so market
making lower lower lows magazine making
higher lows so this is bullish this is a
sign of reversal here then we had this
200 period moving average on the holy
time frame that was clearly resistance
that got broken so right now we're
having a breakout situation with uh i'm
gonna show you that a massive synthetic
shot interest on the upside
so this is looking good this stuff can
squeeze i'm gonna finish technically so
here i see support around 660 630 so i
posted an alert on this uh you guys that
are my discord can of course see it
and i'm going to keep updating you on
the stock because i think that it has a
nice potential now let me show you uh
some marina
the show the synthetic short interest so
for those who are seeing this for the
first time this is a spreadsheet that is
using the option open interest to then
get the synthetic shot that i compute
using the delta using black shorts
formula and i get the synthetic short
and the maximum synthetic short the
difference between those two is the
gamma so let's see here what do we have
for marine
it's still computing
all right so this is the option
distribution so we have a lot on the 10
strike so marine is turning at seven so
higher and we have some on the 20 30
alright so this is creating gamma you
can see the synthetic shot can go from 5
to 12
and when i did that on the 27th of
august the maximum synthetic shot was 8.
it is now 12.1
okay so it grew on friday so this is hot
this is showing you and a lot of people
jumped in to buy some call options and
this is going to create even more uh
gamma on the upside so we're having here
a nice candidate and the market cap is
very small 100 million usd it's small so
a few investors can move this stock so
that's why i think that we might see
some nice move up uh here so once again
um i posted on the network i give you
guys all the details of the threads that
i would do second one okay groupon here
we go so bearish trend for the past 10
years then it woke up after the covey
like many stocks
here we had a small fake out of the down
trend you can see
all right we tried we failed and now we
moved lower so what is the situation
first technically here so i'm going to
go on a forest time frame
okay so this is weak guys okay you here
you can only see weakness we don't have
enough time here the market didn't
consolidate very long
actually almost one month so you can see
that here we have this consolidation
that i'm going to show you how to use
but first we don't have here the nice
bullish reversals yet we don't have any
bullish divergence we don't have any
breakouts it's an early
stage but i'm going to show you guys
what i have on the synthetic short
interest but first look here we have
this consolidation
okay between the 30s okay 10th of august
so for two three weeks the market is
consolidating below 25. so any move
higher than this is a trigger for some
nice moves up and you can see here let's
check the synthetic short interest bam
okay get synthetic short
once again here i'm using all the
maturities that are here
i'm also taking the regular shot as of
the 13th of august that is now available
and i take all this information into
account when i try to identify if it's a
candidate for squeeze i also associate
all this information with the technicals
that are helping me to actually play
those moves so here maximum synthetic
short absolutely massive yes 37
it's one of the biggest i've seen sprt
and bbig are around 70 80 so they're
even higher but they squeezed already
this stuff has not squeezed yet
we have a dtc of five which is a lot
guys above three there is risk all right
but sometimes you have one and it's
still squeezing so it's not the only
indicator you want to look at but it's
already very interesting
so the total shot is right now eight for
now the synthetic shot plus 16 but you
can see guys as we're coming from the
highs there are many many corruptions on
the 30 35 25 so basically the gamma is
huge 30
of synthetic shot that is going to be
created on the upside if all the options
finish in the money so of course we
would need to go very high for that to
happen but uh it's uh possible so market
cap 700 million usd so it's bigger so
it's not as easy to move as those
shorter smaller market caps but it's
definitely a very strong candidate so
same thing guys i added to my squeeze
shortlist and i'm showing you some nice
trade ideas that you could do on my
discord if you want to have a look so
let's see what is happening i think this
week might be uh very interesting we saw
a lot of big moves uh on last week
especially on friday so i'm very excited
to see how things go on monday i'm gonna
keep updating you guys on everything
that i'm saying here don't hesitate to
show me more stocks in the comments i
will have a look at them and if i see
something interesting i will show you so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
you